nous sommes dans la rue Juliette d'udu
c'est une rue commerçante de Saint-Denis
comme on témoigne ses nombreux magasins
elle abrite aussi la plus ancienne
prison du département qui porte
également son nom ainsi que le collège
Juliette daudu réputé pour être un des
meilleurs de lîle mais tout cela ne nous
dit pas qui était Juliette Dadu vous
savez qui était Juliette Dadu pas du
tout la question piège tout de suite une
femme qui a eu une importance dans la
guerre de 70 ou là j j de J d postière
célèbre pendant la guerre de
1870 surtout pour un canularard était
assassiné non to dis elle aurait envoyé
un
télégramme c'est c'est la r fond là dis
les Allemands vont vous attaquer à tel
endroit tout ça tout
ça
Miron ni est perdu d'un quelconque roméo
Juliette Dodu a marqué l'histoire de la
Réunion par son héroïsme notre jeune
dionisienne née le 15 juin 1848 per coup
sur coup son père et son
petit-père Juliette et sa maman quittent
donc la Réunion en 1864 pour le bureau
télégraphique de Pit iier 6 ans plus
tard c'est la guerre en septembre les
Prussiens occupent la viille les coupe
tous les moyens de communication
Pitivier se trouve isolé la jeune fille
aide alors sa mère à rétablir les
liaisons en morse avec l'armée française
pendant 17 nuits la jeune créole
inexpérimentée intercepte les dépêches
ennemies et les retransmet aux autorités
françaises sauvant ainsi la vie des
40000 soldats du général paladine
dénoncé par une servante l'héroïque
réunionnaise est d'abord condamné à mort
pour espionnage avant d'être gracié par
le prince Frédéric Charles de Prusse 2
jours avant l'armistice à libération à
les porter en triomphe telle une Jeane
d'Arc des temps modernes elle reçoit
même la médaille militaire en 1877 et
celle de la Légion d'Honneur l'année
suivante une femme décorée de Tell
distinctions c'est une première dans
l'histoire de France sans jamais être
revenue au pays Juliette s'éteindra en
Suisse à l'âge de 61 ans elle aura droit
à des funérailles nationales à
Paris